i just did a uh several videos on the
binomial theorem so i think it's and now
that they're done i think
now is a good time to do the proof of
the derivative
of the general form
so let's take the derivative of x to the
n
and now that we know the binomial
theorem we have the tools to do it
so how do we how do we take the
derivative well what's the classic
definition of the derivative
it is the limit the limit
as delta x approaches
zero of f of x
plus delta x right so f of x plus delta
x in this situation
is x plus delta x
to the nth power right minus f of x well
f of x here is just x to the n
all of that over delta x
and now that we know the binomial
theorem we can
figure out what this what the expansion
of x plus delta
x is to the nth power and if you don't
know the binomial theorem go to my
precalculus playlist and watch the
videos on the binomial theorem
so the binomial theorem tells us that
this is equal to and let me i'm going to
need some space for this one
the limit as delta x
approaches zero and what's the binomial
theorem channels this
this is going to be equal to i'm just
going to do the numerator
x x to the n
plus n
choose one and once again
review the binomial theorem if this is
looks like latin to you and you don't
know latin
n choose 1 of x
to the n minus 1
delta x plus
n choose 2
x to the n minus 2
that's x n minus 2 delta x
squared right delta x squared and then
plus and we have a bunch of
the digits and in this proof that
actually you know we don't have to go
through all the digits but the binomial
theorem tells us what they are
and of course the last digit you know we
just keep adding
is going to be 1 well you know you could
it would be n choose n which is 1.
let me just write that down n choose n
it's going to be x to the 0
x to the 0 times delta x
times delta x to the n right so that's
the binomial expansion
and let me switch back to minus so all
of that's
what i that green that's x plus delta x
to the n so minus
x to the n minus x
to the n power that's x to the n i know
i squanched it there
all of that over delta x
let's see if we can simplify so first of
all we have an x to the n here and at
the very end we subtract out an x to the
n so these two cancel out
right and then if we look at every term
here
every term in the numerator has a delta
x right so we can divide the numerator
and the denominator essentially by delta
x right we could
this is the same thing as 1 over delta x
times this whole thing so that is equal
to
let me the limit
as delta x approaches 0
of so we divide the top and the bottom
by delta x or we multiply the numerator
times 1 over delta x
we get n
choose 1 x to the
n minus 1. what's delta x divided by
delta x well that's just 1
right plus n
choose 2 x to the n minus 2.
this is delta x squared when we divide
by delta x
we just get a delta x here delta x
and then we have you know we keep having
a bunch of terms we're going to divide
all of them by delta x
right and then the last term is delta x
to the n
but now we're going to divide that by
delta x so the last term
is becomes n choose n and choose n
x to the 0 is 1 so we can ignore that
delta x to the n
divided by delta x well that's delta x
to the n minus 1. right
and then what are we doing now well
remember we're taking the limit
as delta x approaches zero so as delta x
approaches zero pretty much every term
that has a delta x in it
it becomes zero right we just you know
when you multiply by zero you get zero
so every term after this first term has
no delta x in it but every other term
does every other term even after we
divided by delta x has a delta x in it
so that's a zero
every term is zero all of the other i
don't know what is it n minus one terms
they're all zero so all we're left with
is
that this is equal to n choose one
of x to the n minus one
and what's n my n choose one that equals
n factorial over one factorial
divided by n minus 1 factorial
times x to the n minus 1. 1 factorial is
1.
and you know if i have 7 factorial
divided by 6 factorial that's just 7 or
if i have 3 factorial divided by 2
factorial that's just 3. you can work it
out
10 factorial divided by 9 factorial
that's 10. so n factorial divided by n
minus 1 factorial that's just equal to n
so this is equal to n times x to the n
minus 1. so that's the derivative
of x to the n n times x
to the n minus 1. so we just proved the
derivative for
any well for any positive integer when
the with x to the power n where n is any
positive integer
and we see later it actually works for
all uh
actually real numbers in the exponent um
so
i will see you in a future video see ya
oh and another thing i wanted to point
out is
you know i i said that we had to know
the binomial theorem but if you think
about it we really didn't even have to
know the binomial theorem because we
knew
you know in any binomial expansion i
mean you'd have to know a little bit but
if you did a little experimentation you
would realize that whenever you expand
you know a plus b
to the nth power the first term is going
to be a to the n
and then the second term is going to be
plus n
a to the n minus 1 b
right and then you could keep having a
bunch of terms but these are the only
term
terms that are relevant in this proof
because all the other terms get
cancelled out by
you know when delta x approaches 0. so
if you just knew that you could have
done this but it's much better to do
with the binomial theorem
ignore what i just said if it confused
you i'm just saying that we didn't
you we could have just said oh there you
know there's the rest of these terms
just all go to zero
anyway hopefully you found that
fulfilling i will see you in future
videos